ils sont célèbres dans le monde entier
se sont sans jeu de mots des étoiles
comme les mousquetaires ils sont un de
plus comme le croient les premiers
étaient 3 aurait été 4 ceux ci sont
quatre ans étaient cinq
car deux d'entre eux sont des frères je
voulais présenter dans un instant ce
sont les maîtres de la cuisine française
et au même titre que tous les artistes
que nous connaissons pâtre compositeur
écrivain que sais-je ils ont droit à une
très juste célébrités et comme je vous
le disais il y un instant cette
célébrité n'est pas seulement leur fait
en france mais sur toute la planète
ils sont généreux j'entends par là que
leurs secrets leurs recettes les
mystères dont ils sont autour dont on
croit qu'il s'entoure eh bien ils
veulent bien nous les livrer et chaque
semaine sur ce plateau
vous pourrez voir l'un d'eux à tour de
rôle venir composer un menu et surtout
détail et une de ses recettes
je voulais présente maintenant l'un
après l'autre par ordre alphabétique
puisqu'en matière de célébrités l'avons
l'autre le premier dans cet ordre c'est
paul bocuse cuisine de la région
lyonnaise dont il n'est pas besoin de
parler davantage
le second c'est michel guérard michel
guérard les landes mais aussi cuisine de
minceur et cuisine de saveurs pierre
troisgros son frère jean n'est pas là
aujourd'hui mais vous le verrez lui
aussi dans les prochaines semaines alors
c'est les confins du lyonnais et de la
bourgogne et enfin avec la provence tout
ce qu'elle représente pour nous
roger vergé
mais il nous manque quelqu'un est ce
quelqu'un c'est marthe mercadier modesto
ménagères ni modeste mais peut-être
ménagères oui et qu'ils viendraient à
écouter et marthe mercadier sera là non
seulement pour écouter mais pour être
auprès de nos chefs
l'ambassadrice l'interprète plus
exactement des françaises est aussi des
français qui aiment cuisiner et manger
auprès de nous mettre de la cuisine
[Musique]
je pense que la cuisine on peut le
considérer comme de la peinture comme de
la musique on peut peindre avec beaucoup
de produits beaucoup de couleurs on peut
peindre avec des produits beaucoup plus
simple avec un crayon et on arrive à
faire un dessin on peut jouer de la
musique tout seul on peut diriger un
orchestre donc c'est peut-être ici un
peu le cas je dirige une équipe de
cuisiniers
il y a le saucier qui peut remplacer le
premier violon il y a le rôtisseur qui
peut remplacer l'alto et aussi on peut
cuisiner sol et ça aussi c'est très
agréable on peut cuisiner avec des
produits simples on peut jouer de la
grande musique
on peut jouer de la musique très simple
ça ça un peu la même façon mais je crois
quand même que la cuisine a quand même
plus que tout ça puisque finalement on
est obligé de la jouer en direct et
c'est là où ça sent bon et c'est là
vraiment où ça donne faim pour moi la
cuisine c'est ses très longues
je pense qu'il y à quelques musiciens
qui sont doués et qui peuvent jouer très
tôt du piano qui peuvent jouer très tôt
du violon en cuisine c'est pareil il y
arrive dans la maison là certains
apprentis qui arrivent et dès qu'ils
arrivent n'ont jamais fait une source de
salade et ils savent faire une sauce de
salades allait me demander pourquoi je
ne sais pas et il y en a d'autres qui
sont là depuis dix ans qu'ils sont
incapables de faire une sauce de salade
ils n'y comprennent rien mais par contre
ils sont plus doués pour faire un
recueil en a qui sortent en faire plus
rares outils il y en a qui sont jamais
faire cuire une sauce et la musique je
crois que c'est la même chose
je crois être cuisinier c'est quand même
être un peu doué on n'aime pas on aime
cuisiner on aime jouer de la musique
encore hier je relisais le livre
d'escoffier et qui est paru en 1901 on
parle aujourd'hui de salades folle de
salades gourmandes et déjà escoffier en
1901 faisait des salades composées avec
des haricots très peu puis des légumes
très peu cuits des légumes cuits à la
vapeur chose qui revient à la mode
je pense que si vous voulez la cuisine
d'aujourd'hui c'est un peu la mode qui
revient mais une mode dépouillé c'est à
dire qu'on s'habille plus comme les
femmes s'habillaient dans le temps avec
des rafales à des corsets des bottillons
est encore que les bottillons n'en
renvoie donc aujourd'hui si vous voulez
sans devenu plus simple elles sont plus
dépouillé dessous elles sont plus
alertes la cuisine aujourd'hui restait
quand même de la cuisine c'est qu'il
faut pour moi toujours de la crème
comme disait point donnez moi du beurre
encore du beurre et toujours du bord
c'est difficile de faire de la cuisine
avec pas de produit il faut la cuisine
du marché comme j'ai toujours parce que
un cuisinier ou une ménagère ne peut pas
faire de la bonne cuisine si le matin
elle ne va pas au marché acheter ses
produits
les comparer et bien souvent le conseil
que je pourrais donner une ménagère
c'est quand elle va au marché de palais
avec une idée fixe
si l envie d'aller par exemple acheter
une truite ou un saumon et qu'à côté il
ya des merlans merveilleux qui sortent
du bassin qu'il sorte du bassin qui sont
des pêcheurs des macros qui sont là tout
juillet et bien qu'elle achète des
macros qu'elles rentrent chez elles et
qu'elles viennent pas avec des idées sur
et qu'elle fasse ce produit merveilleux
que la trouver si vous marchez c'est le
moment des formes sans nouvelles d'eux
vient manger des pommes d'un nouvel ce
que je pourrais reprocher aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il n'y a plus de saison on veut
des fraises à noël on veut les pommes au
mois de juillet donc restons sérieux la
france est le plus beau pays pour les
produits vivons avec nos produits
moi j'ai commencé en 42 dans un petit
restaurant qui s'appelait colmar s était
un restaurant de guerre où on apprenait
à tuer le cochon a tué le vaud où il
fallait se débrouiller ça je crois que
sam apprentissage aujourd'hui bien sûr
les écoles mais quand on a un gosse qui
part aujourd'hui à 16 ans à l'école qui
fait deux ans d'école qui arrive à 18
ans bien sûr il se raconte et bien sûr
du veau de la gestion bien sûr qu'il
faut ce mot américain que je n'ai jamais
compris foot scott je ne sais pas
d'ailleurs ce que ça veut dire
il faut énormément aujourd'hui tenir ses
affaires mais enfin un bon comptable
c'est beaucoup plus facile qu'à trouver
qu'un bon cuisinier bon aujourd'hui il
va y avoir saucisson chaud en brioche
une volaille au sel gros garni
d'épinards en branche
un fromage et un gâteau de riz avec un
sirop de framboise et comme vin pour
accompagner sa d'un beaujolais villages
voilà une volaille de bresse 5 kg de sel
gros de l'estragon du cerfeuil de la
ciboulette du persil une tête d'ail
il faut un moulin à poivre une cocotte
en fonte du papier d'aluminium et un
four très chaud
m'en vais préparer la volaille donc je
les cartes et
je coupe les pattes ces volailles de
bresse sont des volailles qui sont comme
le vin d'appellation contrôlée
elles sont élevées en plein champ et
nourri au grain elles sont d'une région
très des limites et qui est dans la
bresse et il doit en produire tant à
l'hectare vide et donc il faut bien la
vie des élèves là derrière on détache le
jabot et le gésier c'est à dire qu'il
faut bien enlever cette poche c'est la
poche où il égrène passe bien le doigt
le long du bréchet lelong les poumons
pour enlever les poumons et là on doit
tirer le gésier le foie et les poumons
voilà donc voilà la bolive idée là je la
retourne pour qu'elles soient plus jolie
et plus présentable jeu la bride pour
brider une volaille
il faut bien relever les pattes passé
dans les jointures c'est à dire la bande
la ficelle
voilà ici et cette volaille
je m'en vais la garnir de gousses d'ail
mais 2 gousses d'ail non épluchées car
là ils n'ont épluché parfume saint-trond
prononcé le good eye
alors voilà d'un côté est attaché de
l'autre les pattes
ici donc la volaille est bien mieux
présenter s'il reste quelques petits
canons peut les enlever avec la pointe
d'un couteau
bien sûr on peut s'il reste aussi de
petit duvet la flambée avec un peu
d'alcool devint un petit peu de cognac
qu'on fait allumer et on passe la
volaille sur le la flamme qui brûle
maintenant je m'en vais la garnir de
gousses d'ail mais deux gousses d'ail
non épluchées parce que là ils pas
épluché donne un goût sans trop fort
c'est à dire good eye très agréable
alors on en met beaucoup mais toute la
gousse d'ail à l'intérieur et voilà lola
donc là et on va bout et de bouteilles
alors là dans l'orifice aux médailles
alors oui hélas il y en à peu près pour
8 ou 10 1 voilà qui est bourrée die est
encore une et en voilà encore une
et là maintenant je vais prendre les
airs voilà le printemps les herbes
comment cette bonne alors josh mais
grossièrement parce que je n'aime pas
qu'une herbe soit chercher fine je pense
que ça perdre son goût vers l'estrade on
doit chez le cerfeuil grossièrement
aussi un petit peu de ciboulette parce
que la ciboulette c'est très agréable
aussi grossièrement fait bien sûr un
petit peu de persil tousser
si la roma ton était passé à l'eau
fraîche bien laver voilà très gros
sciemment et maintenant jambon la
volaille
à l'intérieur ça va parfumé toutes ces
herbes avec ses tailles vont faire un
mélange très très très agréable et
maintenant je m'en vais poivrez mes
volailles et toujours pour avouer si
c'est possible avec le poivre du moulin
parce que c'est un poids frais et du
poivre noir
alors je crois je fois à l'intérieur je
poids dessus
bien sûr je ne salue pas hein parce que
déjà avec cinq kilos de sel c'est déjà
pas mal là maintenant je prends un petit
peu la télé tant d'argent et je le mets
là pour empêcher le sel de rentrer à
l'intérieur
alors voilà la volaille je la côtoie la
grande cocotte une grande cocotte en
faut c'est à dire que une cocotte la
otra d'épaisses et jeu-là tapissent de
papier d'aluminium pour éviter que le
sel colophon voilà non celle du sel
gourin j'ai bien dit lui c'est le gros
et du sel groulx marin c'est à dire du
seul groupe qui encore de l'humidité
dedans pas de celle d hydrater le sel
qui va le mieux pour faire placer le
celles qu'on trouve chez son boulanger à
l'envoyer au fond non mais à peu près 2
kg et attention pour mettre la volaille
on ne met pas de sens on la met 200 cela
car au démoulage la volaille se trouve à
du bon côté et maintenant je continue à
remplir de sel mais beaucoup beaucoup de
seul et ça c'est une recette est une
recette chinoise
les chinois le long des plages qui
récupère le sel fondent et harcèlent et
pour cuire leurs dîners à midi ils
enfoui sous un tas de sel aussi bien on
peut mettre gigot on peut mettre une
volaille et sous le tas recel il enfouit
la la volaille et ils font un feu de
bois dessus et le sel c'est fou
donc là on revient au même principe
alors je continue à mettre mancelle il
faut pas avoir peur et attention quand
une recette comme ça ne jamais couvrir
ne jamais couvrir avec un couvercle
parce qu'il se produirait une vapeur la
volaille ce sale ray et ça serait un
désastre
alors maintenant je m'en vais la mettre
au four il faut un four très très très
chaud la gelée me sur 10 c'est à dire le
show au maximum hélas cette volaille
elle va rester comme ça pendant une
heure et bien voilà maintenant une heure
que notre volaille est au four elle doit
être cuit s'il four était chauffée très
très chaud la volaille est cuite
alors on ouvre le four pour la la il se
dégage une odeur diodes car le sel gros
qui est comme ça humides des gages de
l'yonne mélanger avec les herbes l'ail
et le serveur c'est vraiment très très
parfumée bon maintenant on va procéder
au démoulage
il faut la bouche et comment la bouche
un pâté de sable alors je connais une
petite formule qui est plus facile et
moins dangereuse car la cocotte est
lourd on comprenait une une planche
d'où la mettez sur votre cocotte et vous
tournez d'un seul coup comme ceci là il
vaut peut-être mieux prendre les bras
d'un homme parce que c'est lourd 5 kg de
sel plus le poids de la cocotte et voilà
c'est démouler donc vous voyez je vais
me le papier ça empêché de coller et
maintenant je défais
alors là vous avez votre blog de celle
qui est devant vous et il faut le casser
parce que le sel a fait bloc
donc le sel à fait fou à vous prenez un
couteau pointu et vous commencez à
tailler à tailler dans le sel et
attention il faut un four très très très
chaud vous avez votre volaille qui est
bien loti qui sent bon qu'est parfumée
alors là vous l'enlevez vous la prenez
avec une fourchette et vous faites
attention de bien bien enlever le sel
qui est autour le seul gros on est au
tout il n'a pas fondu il l'a juste
effleuré la volaille est là maintenant
va procéder au découpage de la volaille
alors vous voyez vous bien bien la
brosse et du sel 1 il faut bien faut
bien l'enlever parce que s'il reste du
sel gros le seul gros c'est quand même
un petit peu trop salée
à ce moment là vous la mettez c'est
votre choix sur votre place vous pouvez
procéder au découpage de votre volaille
alors vous enlever des petites ficelles
de bridage donc volaille est bien
présente et voilà et alors
j'avais dit au début qu'on pouvait
commencer ce repas avec ceci sans
lyonnais en brioche
s'agissant lyonnais en voyage vous savez
c'est un ceci sans choquer pur porc qui
est cuit à l'eau pendant 20 minutes et
je connais une petite formule pour que
la brioche qui c'est vous qui avez fait
votre cerveau en brioche donc il est
facile aujourd'hui sur le sable en
brioche puisqu'on trouve de la brioche
surge lesquels de bonne qualité
mais il faut une formule pour que la
brioche que le bien bien bien au
saucisson alors quelle est la formule
pour qu un saucisson adhèrent bien à la
brioche c'est facile une fois que
ceux-ci sont et cuits en général vont
cuire un sosie sens il faut le laisser
cuire à peu près 20 minutes dans l'eau
et à ce moment là vous épluchez votre
saucisson et une fois qu'il est épluché
vous le mettez à retire dans un four ça
a pour but de dégraisser entièrement
voyez la volaille admirablement bien
cuite lee resté une heure alors là vous
détacher la cuisse
là vous d'apport pour détacher d'elle
pour partait très loin pour les tâches
et une aile voiliers et là à ce moment
là vous avez une jointure et là vous
c'est très facile un coupé une volaille
c'est une chose qui est très très très
facile et vous savez cette volaille là
elle se mange très facilement
elle peut très bien se faire pour deux
personnes et puis s'ils en restent
froids qu'est ce que c'est bon surtout
que vous allez sûrement l'aménager
l'agrémenter d'un peu de beaujolais d'un
peu de beaujolais villages et vous savez
beaujolais villages chez nous on le sert
très frais on le met même dans le dos
avec de la glace
et puis 75 est une bonne année mais 74
c'était quand même une meilleure année
et si vous avez encore un peu de 74 but
bien frais avec cette volaille au seul
gros ça sera très bon à l'envoyer là
pour découvrir votre voilà il je
continue vous marquez bien jusqu'au bout
et à ce moment là avec votre fourchette
vous détacher et là votre cuisse elle
vient tout seul
et voilà donc tout est détaché et j'ai
dit que pour servir avec cette volaille
la chose merveilleuse c'était de faire
un petit peu d'épinards en branche et
pour faire les épinards en branche
là aussi c'est une formule vous prenez
une casserole dans votre casserole bon
morceau de beurre l'épinard est bien peu
embêtant il est gourmand en beurre donc
il faut mettre le beurre et 4 le beurre
arrive noisette
moi je suis un peu un penchant pour
l'ail est toujours là et en chemise
parce que l'ail en chemise nomme beurre
je mets un petit peu mon aille à frémir
dans mon beurre et comme beurre noisette
je me dis pignard engrangé vous savez
que pour l'épinard en revanche un tour
le bout ça suffit je les plombs
dans mon beurre noisette à ce moment là
tout se marie tous mus et en même temps
que la volaille on servira ses épinards
en branche
un coup de poivre du moulin parce que le
poivre du moulin ça aussi c'est un une
formule merveilleuse alors là la
volaille je continue à la découpe et
donc je fais exactement le sens opposé
de tout à l'heure là vous détacher bien
votre aile et une fois que la volaille
et coupe et demi dans votre plat
toujours toujours un petit coup de
poivre du moulin parce que le poivre du
moulin
toujours dernier moment il faut poivrer
et voilà vous allez me dire et les
herbes et like et les intérieurs
ça a été uniquement pour parfumer les
chers comme le sel enfin bon appétit
[Musique]